crushing touchdown and a passing
touchdown in all three halves okay well
Anderson doing damage
Cole what you see I see you can't you
can't wait to read a mess point with a
guy that can attack the football that
fast you just can't do it will Anderson
wants to attack he is in attack mode on
almost every play you can read him from
the 15.
[Applause]
and they'll hand it off to Robinson he's
bottled up and he'll be dropped for
maybe a five-yard loss Will Anderson
with pressure field here he is that left
defensive end but he plays about as hard
as anybody out there watch him run down
Bijan Robinson from that left side
nowhere for Robin
that's exactly what you said partner
Anderson here's Anderson over here on
this left side of the offense and wants
you pauses for a moment and then he's
out of there Boom
Card has no chance trying to get that
ball out to the right side he's trying
to get into his tight end jatavian
Sanders has nowhere to go with it
regardless big turnover what a play by
Driggers but that gives Will Anderson a
chance to make some plays it's a loss of
three as Will Anderson is
quickly they get it off it is
intercepted this is Will Anderson Jr
touchdown
you know it is it's almost like a jump
ball and I can promise you will Anderson
is going to win all of those
look at the length that this guy plays
with he's always around the football
especially when it's still in the
offensive backfield
Chandler Rogers to Malik Jackson and
he's met by several Defenders including
Anderson for another loss defensive
front
Jaheim oh it's where he gets back there
Otis and he's just disruptive on this
third and nine
tries to escape but Anderson is capable
to get to him
will they call the horse collar though
here stench it looks like that's what
the penalty is
he grabbed his pads but watch this
they're trying to run a game with Will
Anderson he gets hung up he bounces into
Byron young slows him down actually
helped him and yeah
Anderson got there
it was a simple full race and Will
Anderson with the sack for Alabama is
just leave him one on one with the left
tackle Gunner Hanson
I mean that just
you can't ask
a left tackle
on a third long situation wasn't the
tallest one the fastest wasn't the
strongest but the guy just knew the game
and knew how to play it well they sack
him again converging on Swan Will
Anderson Junior and Chris Braswell
Jefferson land who should have caught
that last pass and now he's going to get
sacked
[Applause]
pick up a 20 to the 35.
Jefferson has time now running out of it
and goes down it's probably going to be
a sack if we went around the line of
scrimmage where Tim Smith brought him
down here good timeout nobody open zoned
nothing there tries to scramble and
close down
second down and ten Collision in the
backfield and Will Anderson says hello
to Rocket Sanders you better read it
fast because he's coming and if you make
the wrong decision
they're lucky he didn't take the handoff
oh wow
that's a yeah I don't know his first
half they've done that it was a penalty
and a putt by the way they didn't mean
anything Roger's gonna be swallowed up
by Will Anderson who has terrorized the
Bulldogs the last couple of years Jones
has the unimviable task of trying to
deal with the best pass rusher we've
seen in college football in a long time
the back releases looked like he
actually grabbed onto his face mask to
try to help him out but one on one this
is like being down at mobile right at
the Senior Bowl you're going to do a
one-on-one drill with 31 You're Gonna
Lose just it's just the rules for the
game he's been surging 16 catches the
last three games Kevin looks his way yet
Daniels
in the pocket pinballing around and Will
Anderson and Company knock him down
Turner was there as well toe toe also
kind of coming in on from the outside
not letting him go anywhere not letting
him Escape just keep him inside if
you're number five there you've got
to have an internal clock you know
never made it count yet
from the 25 Daniels under immediate
pressure off the edge and cannot Escape
will Anderson gets home third sack for
Bama will Anderson's been lining it up
on the other side oh my gosh there's
nothing you can prepare yourself
in trouble
downs and it's Will Anderson
left side outside
cone nice stunt inside isn't it
beautiful job that time
lines up outside all right here we go
we're gonna play football with 6 36 to
go Auburn a chance to make this again
and on
the direct snap they could have bought
themselves the mistake and got out of it
as it is the Tigers still driving second
and one Ashford swarmed under by Will
Anderson first sack of the game by
either team and for him the 34th of his
career well Anderson pushed this guy
actually he shoved cure back into him
and actually tackles sacked them before
Will Anderson touched him that was great
[Applause]
foreign
step out of bounds Anderson make sure
that he did a loss of about five